you now Biden continues to ignore the
crisis that he himself created at our
Southern border as 2024 GOP candidates
have vow to close it as of course the
disaster is now impacting cities and
small towns in every corner of this
country a fatal stabbing at a migrant
shelter in New York City is now shedding
more light on the dangerous conditions
inside the camps and yesterday a group
of illegal immigrants tried to steal
over $55,000 worth of sunglasses from uh
a New York City blooming Dells the
problem has gotten so bad that city
leaders there are now pleading for help
from the administration Denver's
Democratic mayor is now calling for
federal support for the quote
unsustainable crisis in his city the
city officials in the small city of
Whitewater Wisconsin they're asking for
help as they say the influx of illegal
immigrants is putting a strain on
resources there here with reaction
reaction former acting ice director Tom
Holman and Fox News contributor uh Sarah
Carter by the way Tom Sarah you're part
of a new group called what border
911.com if I'm not mistaken
Tom yeah it's it's a nonprofit um
Sarah's a part of it I I I started a
nonprofit it's a 501c3 C4 border 911.com
it's a it's a bunch of US immigration
border experts who are going to spend
the next year educating American people
on why border security matters so when
they get to the voting booth they vote
for border security cuz border security
means National Security you know Sarah
you've been down there so many times
you and you have chronicled uh how badly
that these illegal immigrants are being
treated by the cartels we know about the
opioid and Fentanyl crisis in the
country but what scares me the most is
the sheer number of people that they've
allowed in unvetted coming from
countries like Iran and Syria and Egypt
and Afghanistan and China and Russia why
would people from those parts of the
world be making making their way to our
Southern border are they all coming here
because they just want better lives for
themselves and their families or you
think maybe there could be Terror cells
walking across our
border oh absolutely guaranteed
guaranteed there are Terror cells that
have made their way into our country
with this wide open border policy and
Sean you were just discussing even with
Michelle Obama and Barack Obama this is
their policy too this open borders
non-sovereign policy so Americans have
to understand that it's just that
President Biden is so terrible at it
right he is so terrible at delivering
the message and Americans are seeing it
across the board this border has been
wide open we know now 32% only approve
of Biden's immigration policy I'd like
to know who that 32% is but right now
what we're seeing is a wide open border
December numbers were through the roof
with over
300,000 people coming in and let me make
this clear over
85% this is what we're hearing right now
Bill maluan reported on it earlier I've
been talking to sources that are saying
the same thing over 85% are being
immediately released into the country so
what we're seeing in Chicago what we're
seeing in New York what we're seeing in
Denver in Dayton Ohio and and to top it
off and Border 911 is really focused on
this as well is the over
112,000 fentol deaths so Sean you're
right this is a national security alarm
that is going off so loud that the
American people have one chance and one
chance only in 2024 to turn our nation
into a right direction and end this open
border policy before it destroys our
country well I I think it's happening I
mean you know in in many ways the fact
that they we had secure borders under
President Trump Tom Homan and now
they're not secure and they abandoned
all the policies that were working you
know I I would say they're going to have
blood on their hands they already have
blood on their their hands in terms of
allowing these drugs into every crevice
every corner of our country and and
don't seem to care they don't seem to
care about the human trafficking on top
of it they don't seem to care at all
about you know vetting people from
countries are our top geopolitical foes
that's scares The Living Daylights out
of me you get the last
word look I've done this since 1984 Sean
I spent you know 34 years doing this job
and you're right if president Trump was
still the president and I was the ice
director these people wouldn't be in New
York City they'd be sitting in ice
detection facility waiting to be
deported and you're right they don't
this Administration has no Humanity a
record number of migrants have died on
us soil Crossing Borders over 1,700 a
record amount of Americans have died
from fany overdoses the sex trafficking
in women children are up
600% the the the rest of people on the
terrorist watch list is is in the is
over 300 just on the Southwest border
four years under Trump 11 3 years under
Biden over 300 this is a national
security failure of huge proportions and
I'm scared I'm scared to death of what's
coming it's coming and it's because this
Administration purposely purposely
unsecured our border the most secure
border of my lifetime they tore it down
intentionally clear and present danger
no doubt about it we appreciate you both
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else